yes now do break it all down Fox News
contributor Karl Rove I'm not somebody
Karl that ever gets ahead of an election
we both know the weekend before an
election who knows what's going to come
out but right it's certainly the economy
how hard left the Democrats have gone
their slate of candidates how do you see
it at least
what is it building into yeah look I
thought that was interesting Steve
Rattner who's no friend of Donald
Trump's he was Barack Obama's autos are
wrote a piece in The New York Times
pointing out all these Econometrica
models in the election are today
forecast into Trump victory but I'd say
we got to be cautious about this cannot
get overconfident cannot believe that
because the models predict that today
that that's what's going to happen
because if you look at it over time the
economy and who you vote for for
president is a non-linear relationship
that's what we call it him in polling
terms what that means is is it an
incumbent absolutely gets punished for a
bad economy if you're Herbert Hoover
you're in deep trouble in 1932 on the
other hand a good economy is not
necessarily rewarded as much or
consistently particularly if you don't
do two critical things or it should be
three critical things an election isn't
coming
talk about your success talk about the
next step and disqualify your opponent
as representing a threat to your to that
economic growth can I give you one
real-life example that you and I've been
through right towards back thank
goodness where's the been unemployment
rate in October of 2000 was three point
nine percent today it's it's three point
six the real GDP growth in 2000 was two
point nine seven growth last year in
2019 two point nine seven now this was
the clinton-gore third election this was
Al Gore running to be the third term of
Bill Clinton and they had a good economy
now it was slowing down we were in a
recession by the next March but it was a
good economy as we approach the election
and the Econometrica models were
forecasting a victory for Al Gore but he
didn't talk about it he sure as heck
never talked about what the
steps were for for clinton-gore and he
never succeeded in disqualifying George
W Bush who proactively talked about what
was necessary to spread prosperity more
broadly which was to cut the taxes and
lower the regulation that were focus on
teaching every child to learn to read so
yet we got to be the election is about
whatever the candidates want to say it's
about as long as the people accept it
and if the president is going to use the
economy to his advantage he has to do
those three things talk about it explain
the next steps and disqualify the
Democrat opponent I had also spiked to
see the Republican Party unite and I
want to nationalize this election as a
big choice election Green Deal no
mullahs in Iran get 150 billion or the
Trump success deregulation lower taxes
safest security brought simple sometimes
in a cutting a comment wants it to be
about little things
president Trump Fattah has to make it
about big things in order to overcome
what he's facing are we better off than
we were two and a half years ago yes we
are
Karl Rove good to see you